Prime Minister and partly as a result of
some of the things that have been said
even by yourself at this conference
sterling has fallen to a 31 year low is
that a success well what have I been
saying at this conference what I've been
doing is setting out some greater
certainty about the process that we have
will have for leaving the European Union
and about the timing for us triggering
the formal negotiations which will lead
to that exit from the European Union and
I thought it was important to set that
out so that people could see that the
plan that the United Kingdom government
has in terms of approaching this I think
that has given people a greater
certainty over the timing and over the
process and that's been important but
when sterling Falls to lower we haven't
seen against da since 1985 does it seem
like a confident verdict well of course
we see sterling moving in different ways
at different times but if you look
overall at some of the economic data
that has been coming out over the last
few months actually the data has been
more positive than people were expecting
that that to be it's early days of
course but i think the impression is
that the response has been rather karma
to the brexit vote than many people had
predicted all thought might happen what
I want to ensure it is that as we go
forward we have a smooth process of
exiting the European Union as possible
that's why I have set out this week that
we will trigger article 50 which will
start that formal process of negotiation
by the end of march next year it's why
I've set out that we will repeal the
european communities act and bringing
you law into UK law so at the point at
which we leave the European Union
employers and workers have the
confidence of knowing what the situation
will be rather than being a great gap in
UK law at the time Prime Minister one
things have played out in the fringes of
this conference is that representative
of industry of aviation auto the city
have expressed concern all realized that
the brexit that's coming may limits
access or membership of the single
market and the customs union and this is
one of the responses is that a fair
interpretation they're beginning to
worry a little bit about their
industries I think it's important when
we look at what we're going to be
negotiate
we want to get the right deal for the UK
I think it's important that we look at
this not in a sense of sort of either
where we're trying to if you like see
which bits of membership we can keep
we're going to be an independent
sovereign country outside of the
European Union and the question is what
is the right relationship for us to have
with the EU now I'm very clear about
that I want the relationship that gives
the best possible opportunity for our
businesses to trade in with and to
operate within the European Union and of
course for European businesses to be
able to trade with us and operate within
the UK and what we're doing as a
government what I've done is sat down
with businesses lit both large and small
here in the UK I've sat down with
American investors in to the UK and talk
to them about where their priorities are
where their concerns are it's not all
good to be plain sailing there will be
some bumps in the road but what I want
to ensure is that we get the right deal
for the UK look at the history of your
party of this conference and one of your
predecessors almost exactly 30 years ago
signed the deal the single European act
brought Britain into the single market
was seen as warned of Margaret
Thatcher's great successes what is the
problem for you with membership of the
single market that was such a
achievement of your party and your
predecessor well feisal I think it as
I've just said it's important for us to
consider what the position of the UK is
going to be we will be an independent
sovereign country and the question is
what is our relationship what is the
relationship we want in the future with
the EU nao as I say I want that
relationship to have the best possible
deal the maximum opportunity for UK
businesses to be able to trade with and
to operate within that market in the
European Union which is the single
market but we need to approach this to
make sure we get the right deal for the
United Kingdom not looking at models
that already exist but saying what's
going to work for us you know we've got
very strong fundamentals in our economy
fifth largest economy in the world this
is about a partnership a relationship
with European Union which is going to be
in the best interest of the UK so
important speech tomorrow are you
abandoning some of the Conservatives
free market principles no there's no
question of abandoning
conservative free market principles but
what I will be doing in my speech is
setting out I've already talked about
brexit I'm going to be setting out the
sort of economic and social reform I
want to see that will deliver on what
we've been talking about here at our
conference which is a country that works
for everyone that's an economy that
works for everyone where the benefits of
growth has spread around the country
where everyone plays by the same rules
as a society that works for everyone
where everyone has the opportunity to go
as far as their talents will take them
to be what they want to be